[LAUGHTER]
>> IT'S TIME FOR THE FINAL SPEED
GAME.
ONE OF REDDIT'S POPULAR FEATURES
IS ASK ME ANYTHING WITH COLLECT
TEASE AND/OR OTHER INTERESTING
PEOPLE OR FROM THE REDDIT
COMMUNITY.
OUR VERSION IS SIMILAR ALTHOUGH
FOR EACH FUNNY QUESTION YOU ASK
YOU GET 250 POINTS BUT TODAY A
RESTAURANT IN PHILLY UNVEILED A
NEW TWINKIE BURGER WELCOME TO
YOUR HEART ATTACK.
JUST IN CASE YOU GUYS ARE
WONDERING WHAT THAT IS, THAT'S A
PORK BELLY PATHY BETWEEN A
TWINKIE BUN CHOPPED WITH CHEESE
AND FOR GOOD MEASURE TOPPED WITH
EXTRA BACON.
THE THING WITH TWINKIES IS
THEY'RE NOT SAVORY SO.
COMEDIANS, I'M THE NEW DEEP
FRIED TWINKIE BURGER.
ASK ME ANYTHING.
60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND GO.
YES MATT BESSER.
>> IS THAT BACON STRIP YOUR
TONGUE OR YOUR DICK.
>> A FAIR QUESTION.
YES, SCOTT AUKERMAN.
>>AN I GET YOU AS A LETTUCE
WRAP.
>> MEGAN.
>> WILL YOU CAUSE EXPLOSIVE OR
JUST GOOD OLD FASHION DIARRHEA.
>> THAT'S IT.
>> IS THAT A PHOTO OF YOU BEFORE
YOU EAT IT OR AFTER I VOMIT YOU.
>> MEGAN.
>> WHAT KIND OF DIABETES WILL I
GET FROM YOU.
>> THAT'S A FAIR ENOUGH
QUESTION.
YES.
>> DID YOU EMERGE FROM PAULA
DEAN'S [BLEEP]
[LAUGHTER]
>> I THINK THE CORRECT ANSWER IS
YES.
YES, SCOTT AUKERMAN.
>> THERE'S PROBABLY SOMEONE